with us now is Dan seen or former
adviser to House Speaker Paul Ryan he
has been talking to Republican members
of Congress since the mother firing
story broke dan always good to see more
Niguel so I'm wondering are the
Republicans saying that this is a
bombshell report what are they saying
it's another example I spoke to a couple
I was poking around last night speaking
to Republican members of Congress to get
a handle on what was going on on the
immigration reform proposal and the
story pops like forget about the
immigration proposal there's this kind
of a big deal
I was curious about whether or not the
story came out because there is another
effort by the White House to contain
something Trump is about to do that this
was almost like a shot being fired
because they were worried about that he
was gonna do something and the
impression I got was no this story is
probably in the works per month for
months it's kind of dated however it is
another example of the lengths that the
senior levels of this administration go
to to contain the present from his worst
instincts you're seeing it with the DOJ
pressure right now on congressional
Republicans on Nunez about releasing
that memo that would be problematic this
example you know McGann possibly Kelly
concert you're Dan that he wanted to do
that it's it's extremely worried
somebody wanted to do it but since the
firing of Comey it does seem that the
infrastructure around him protects him
from his worst instincts in terms of the
Republican leadership they've supported
this president a lot on certain things
went farther than some might have
thought but on the question of Muller
they have not gone as far as the
president has he has raised questions
about him they've said no he's an honest
guy doing it on his job he's that break
between the president and Gresham
leadership is that in evidence here on
this question of firing Muller yeah I
still believe that the that there's sort
of like a fort around Mahler that
congressional Republicans at least
congressional Republican leadership are
prepared to defend now again they will
say you know good news bad news bad news
is he was considering this the good news
is since the firing of Comey it's
there's another example after example of
at least him being responsive to the
people around him and not letting him do
these things let's check quickly in on
that immigration question the White
House has put out a plan it has a path
to citizenship for 1.8 million daca
eligible recipients 25 billion for the
border wall and extended family chain
migration and end the visa lottery
program that's the white house offering
how's it being received I think it was a
very def
I mean I don't agree with everything in
the proposal but I think it was a deftly
drafted piece of legislation because it
basically far exceeds on daca anything
that you know the critics of the
administration's immigration policy
thought he would go one he goes two and
a half times the current daca
permit holders all these people who were
eligible with never registered so I
think it you know it makes it harder for
moderate Republicans like susan collins
lisa murkowski jeff flake to vote
against it and red state Democrats
mansion hide camp Donnelly I mean it
also box I think it caught them
flat-footed so I think there is the
potential to build this coalition I
think the risk is with the immigration
hardliners yeah I mean last night I was
hearing and seeing immigration some of
those from the immigration restrictions
community saying you know calling the
White House and calling conservative
Republican members of Congress saying
wait a minute where we're going beyond
it's one thing if you want to do a clean
trade you know some kind of path to
legal status for the current documents
in return for a border wall okay we can
get arms from that but you're going
beyond that and it's basically amnesty
so I think them holding the hardline
Republican relation restriction is in
check is the central you know to holding
this coalition together and it's gonna
be challenging you know thank you so
much good be with you guys